ViviCorps, thanks for the gifted.
Hello, everybody.
Hold on, I gotta turn on my fan.
It's kind of hot in here.
It's hot because I'm ready to make.
Oh, no, wait.
Hold on, I forgot something.
Some hot.
Deal.
I had my glasses on the whole time.
I thought that I forgot.
Whoopsie.
I thought I forgot my glasses, but I had them on my head the
whole time.
Anyway, I am so sick of listening to this music.
Hold on, ViviCourt, thank you for the five more gifted.
Thank you.
I said thanks for the super chat, and I saw someone else.
I think it was you, Sprank, am I right?
Oh my gosh.
Yes, thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much.
I recognize your cat.
We're no bald.
Gosh, there we go.
Start.
Bald, of course.
That's how we would want it.
Right, Mr. Mando?
Yeah.
I know I'm kind of big right now, but don't worry, I'll get
smaller.
Andrey goes, thanks for the time gift.
Are you ready for some of the most disturbing models in the
history of Wii Shovelware?
Only taught by Iron Chef for Wii.
Okay, so I have seen...
Because I tested this.
I have seen the very soulless, scary models that stand in
the background of this game.
It's quite something to view.
I am so ready.
Oh my god.
I am so ready to make some money, baby.
I'm so ready.
Or lose all my money.
Who knows?
I actually don't know how this game works.
Deal.
Or no deal.
So, look at this.
Also, this has, like, custom games.
So I think you can rig it.
Play a game of deal or no deal with custom settings of your
choosing.
You can rig the game.
Okay, boy.
Could I get a happy birthday for Garfield?
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Garfield.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
Garfield.
This is Garfield's birthday today, you guys.
This is why we're playing Deal or No Deal.
Look, there's challenges.
Series of games with specific goals that test your luck,
skill, and endurance.
Mini-games that are fast and fun.
You can play against the computer or some friends and extras
oh oh never mind extras is nothing it's just the credits why
would you put it under extras then what's under the mini
games push your luck play a game of chance to win some fast
cash sharp shooter test your shooting skills in this fun
game FBA blackjack they have blackjack try your hand at good
old 21 dealer no Real style!
Literally eating veggies, lasagna.
Gamble, gamble, marathon.
Play all three mini-games in a row against friends or the
AIs.
GW.
And leaderboard.
We'll try these later, right?
Minto, you ready to see those hot babes?
Oh, you know it.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so ready.
I'm so ready to see some hot babes.
Non-minto.
Okay.
TV show style, though.
Okay, so.
I don't know deal or deal or deal or deal or deal or deal.
Deal or no deal that well.
I think it's, okay.
You open up some boxes and they have money inside.
And then there's a banker guy who's like, I'm going to offer
you some money.
I think.
Or something.
I don't actually quite know.
Okay.
You pick a box and hope it's a big number.
No, don't you hope it's a small number?
Don't you, aren't you trying to eliminate the small numbers
and then you get the big numbers from the bank?
Can I buy a vowel?
Oh, I have a me that I created.
My shit.
I wonder if...
If you could tell which one it was mine.
Okay.
If you delete this media from the main channel, you will not
delete this profile.
You will be assigned a default character.
Cool.
I also, it's really hard to move on this, on the Wii.
kind of got his name wrong so I have really shaky hands I
was trying to write it out hopefully that doesn't mess me up
in this in the future play a game of deal or no deal where
you're trying to pick the case with the million dollars or
walk out with as much money as possible played over a series
of rounds remove cases oh it totally explains it remove
cases until the banker makes an offer for your case accept
the offer and go home or keep playing to try and win even
more special events such as the million dollar mission can
help you win even more money so have some fun trying to beat
the banker we're gonna beat his butt the sad thing is that
the eyebrows are not united it wouldn't let me if I I tried.
I tried.
It's knowledge snared.
Howie.
I'm Howie Mandel.
Ladies, please.
Oh my god, here they come.
Wow.
Holy moly.
Oh, wow.
Oh god.
Not a single one of them is blinking.
Ladies, please.
Ladies, please back up.
Oh, God.
So scary, Lee.
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Ooh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
Skinny snake.
Hi, Howie.
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money
placed there by a third party.
Most people in the background.
But we do know one case is holding one million dollars.
Woo!
Sorry if the audio is like so weird.
It's loud and then it's not loud.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, take a vote.
I get to pick a case.
Okay, guys.
Time to pick a case.
Now in my brain, I'm thinking four.
14 or 24 but also maybe we should pick it by house I mean
they're all really sexy so it's hard to say right 4 pick
number 4 26 no I think that's bad luck to pick the very last
case right 3 pick mama number 3 my lord I mean 4 okay a lot
of Oh, I'm nervous.
Okay, I'm going to go with four.
I'm going to go with my gut.
You!
Oh, gay, Kayla.
That's your case to keep, to take home, to spend, do
whatever you want, unless you should decide to sell it.
Let's find out if we've got a million dollars in there.
You ready?
Dark.
Let's start by opening up six cases.
Five gifted.
Okay, so we're opening six cases.
All right, what's our first case?
we got gala happy pride everybody oh my goodness what could
be the first case we go with this girl kind of looks like me
though right maybe i should start with her i gotta knock out
i gotta knock her out she kind of looks like me gala and
icon did her parents hate her 12 okay i see someone said 12
where's 12 right here take a number 12 out why is snake look
open the case open the case oh no why are you cheering
that's a lot of money
oh okay i guess compared to a million dollars you have to
open up five more cases okay five more cases guys but it's
not a million okay we want the million to be in number four
the one that we grabbed right i love the dance oh my gosh
you guys i'm nervous 22 i don't know about you i'm feeling
22 you open the case open the case five dollars
yippee okay nice nice nice the audience everything i think i
feel like we are literally in the Twilight Zone right now.
Him silently jumping.
Okay, guys, next one.
It's gotta be seven.
I'm thinking 16.
I don't know.
I'm gonna take out 16.
Okay, hold on.
I lost the wheat.
Hold on.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
16.
I'm taking out 16.
If I can press it.
Okay.
Go with your gut.
Melanie!
Please, open the case.
Open the case.
Oh, oh.
Not bad.
It could be worse.
Okay, three cases left, though.
Three cases left, you guys.
Okay, come on.
Seven?
Seven.
I saw seven first.
I'm gonna go with seven.
Come on, come on.
That's bad.
No, it's fine.
If seven is even higher, I'm gonna scream.
25!
Yippee!
Do a dance, Snake.
Oh, never mind.
Just gonna stand there.
Heretic!
Happy birthday!
Two cases left open.
Two.
Who is breathing?
I...
Do you guys hear someone breathing?
They're like...
10?
13?
I see 10.
10 is one of the ones that you guys wanted me to pick, so...
Something very uncanny about this.
Open the case.
You gotta look in the direction.
One cent!
You guys wanted me to pick this fucking box!
Are you kidding me?
You guys were trying to jinx me!
It's literally the lowest number!
You guys wanted me to go home with nothing!
Okay, last case you guys, last case.
19!
She's cute.
I promise you the answer is 18.
Oh, sorry, Michi.
She's cute though.
Wait, what was her name?
Gian.
5,000.
They're happy about that.
The crowd is pleased.
They will not eat us yet.
Okay, what's happening now?
Not too bad.
There's a man in this room with just one job.
And it's a nasty job.
And his job is to get you out of here for as little as
possible.
Why is Howie so small?
He's looking at the board.
He's looking at you and he wants to buy that case for as
little as possible.
He's working it out.
That's the banker right there.
I see him up there.
What do you think is going to happen?
I don't know!
Hello.
Hello?
Okay.
Yeah?
What's the offer?
Right.
He looks like the villain and Detective Conan.
The new offer?
Oh!
63,000!
Deal or no deal?
Oh, he said the thing!
He said the thing!
Did you?
Or no deal?
I think no deal.
That's a terrible offer.
Terrible offer.
They're only allowed to blink once they open a case.
Till then only constant solace starts.
Deal or no deal?
No deal.
I believe in my case.
He's pondering.
He doesn't know what to do.
No deal!
I was going to say nobody cared about that, I guess.
to open why does this sound like I'm in a serial killer like
sounds like I'm in a thriller show okay I know Michi said 18
so I'm gonna go with that I'm seeing some people say one
I'll go with that next 18 Michelle open the case don't let
me down.
$50?
Nice, nice, nice.
True crime, BT.
Okay.
Four cases.
I'm going to go with one.
Numeral Uno, everybody.
Numeral Uno.
If I can click it.
You.
Open the case.
okay 10 000 that's like that's like that's less than what
was our offer though so we're still okay i think right not
bad it's okay it's okay we're trying to get the left column
okay three cases left you guys i'm sweating so bad oh my god
you're me trying to win an oscars five okay i'm seeing five
Who is breathing?
Open the case.
Oh, my God.
No, five was bad.
Camille.
Oh, oof.
Oof.
Not good.
Two cases left open.
Eight.
23.
We haven't gotten any up here, really.
Just a few.
Let's do 23.
23.
Okay, I think I'm gonna save 11 for last.
She's just gonna stand in there in the middle.
Please open the case.
Oh my god, snake's like, come on.
Don't clap, everyone!
Teresa, no!
No!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
One more case.
I think I'm gonna single out 11 as much as possible.
possible let's go to 17 i think i'm gonna go to 17.
i'm trusting my gut 13 is totally a lucky number okay fine
i'll get 13 out of the way
you guys tell me tell me if it's good or not tell me tell me
what the damage is do i got it doc is it terminal it's a
terminal ten dollars you be They're all like clapping in
sync.
What do you think is going to happen?
I don't know, Howie.
I don't know.
Hello.
How about?
Okay.
Moshi, moshi.
Oh, my God.
Really?
Okay.
What do you mean, really?
The people in the audience are so...
The offer did go.
It went up.
Deal or no deal.
You guys, this is pretty good.
83,000.
dollars that's pretty good no deal we want at least a
hundred k you know what you're so right no deal why is howie
the most realistic look no deal no deal
what if i have the one million okay four cases my lucky
number Oh.
Oh.
For some reason my eyes went to nine first.
My lucky number.
My second lucky number.
Oh.
21.
Blackjack.
All or nothing.
Oh gosh.
I don't know.
21.
Hmm, you.
Open the case.
Karen!
Oh!
Gosh, we have so many, like, 100, 200.
We have so many.
I'm not listening to you guys ever again.
I'm going with nine.
It's my gut.
Baka, baka, baka, baka, baka.
Emily, Please, open the case.
Emily, I believe in you.
300!
Nice.
Thank you.
The what?
The what with the goatee?
Two cases left over.
Also, Zachary, sorry to tell your stream I was just now.
Thanks for getting the Minta Matara merch.
I love it.
Your standies are on my bookshelf.
I have a bag to carry my stuff walking home from work.
Yippee!
Thank you.
26 is free.
Okay, I'm seeing several 26s.
25.
I'm gonna close my eyes and pick one.
I don't know which one I just did.
25!
Open the case.
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Oh my god.
One more case.
Don't open 20.
Why?
You're making me want to open.
11 is sus.
You know what?
I'm going to knock 11 out.
I'm going to get rid of this.
I'm going to get rid of...
There's going to be a big old gap in the middle.
Get out of here, 11.
Open the case.
Oh!
It was sus in a bad way.
Here comes the offer.
Okay, here comes the offer.
Oh god, oh god.
Hello.
Let's see the future mince case has $1.
No, it doesn't.
Okay.
Freak Phantom.
A new offer?
Oh!
Close, but no cigar.
Deal or no deal?
Deal?
Take the deal, mince.
No!
It's not six figures yet.
It's so close.
But I'm gonna have to pay taxes on that.
No deal!
I believe in my case.
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Why did he just...
He doesn't do anything.
Okay, three cases.
Don't give mint money?
Yes, sir.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
That banker looked like a boss, baby.
Three?
Pick number three, my lord.
I'm Shari King!
Open the case.
Oh, okay.
Could be worse.
Oh, gosh.
There's a whole lot of blanked-out numbers on the right
side.
There's a whole lot of...
Two cases left open.
You guys!
I'm scared.
I was thinking eight.
Seven, eight, nine.
eight Audra don't let me down Audra Audra Audra yes Audra I
was gonna say you're too hot to let me down there's still
one dollar up on the board oh but also one million dollars
one case I can I feel the knife that how he is off screen
but He's, like, holding it up to my neck right now, you
know?
14!
Why are you guys trying to jinx me?
You're aiming to win a dollar, right?
Stop!
Oh my gosh.
Six?
Oh, six is down here in the corner.
Barely even...
It's just... It's hiding away, you know?
Six!
Hannah, Hannah, Hannah, Hannah.
I should have left you in the corner.
Hannah, what are you doing to me?
Okay, Barn, thank you.
Remember an episode of the actual show where a guy's wife
forced him to take the deal and then it turned out he had
the million.
Hello.
Oh, okay.
That doesn't sound good.
Oh.
It sounds bad.
The offer is going to be so long.
Oh, it's gonna be so bad.
The offer did go.
It went up!
Deal or no deal.
You guys, I wanna believe in my case.
I wanna believe in my case.
I want to believe in the four.
Believe in the four!
I want...
You know what?
I think we have the one million.
We have the one million.
Deal, deal, deal.
No deal!
Ta-da!
There's still a million dollars!
Two cases left over.
Wait, spitters, exactly.
You have the one dollar.
No, I don't!
24?
26?
20?
Let's go with 26.
You over there.
Elizabeth.
Open the case.
Ah!
Nice!
Guys, we might win this.
One more case.
Oh,
17?
24?
I'm going to go with, I'm seeing a lot of 15s.
You guys don't let me down.
Come on, snage stairs.
Amy.
Please open the case.
What is this angle?
Okay, okay, okay.
We're clapping.
We're stoic clapping.
We have three numbers on each side.
I think our offer is going to go up.
Okay.
I'll tell him.
All right.
Love you too.
It barely went up.
Deal or no deal?
Banker looking desperate.
You don't think he ever says that too?
Thanks, mom.
This dream is going to turn my way.
My feathers, boy.
No deal.
No deal, you guys.
Come on.
I'm not a sucker.
I'm no sucker.
No deal.
One more case.
Just one?
17.
Right smack dab in the middle.
Aw.
Please, open the case.
Open the case.
you guys i think we have a dollar
you guys i think we have just one dollar
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god it's gonna go up
it's gonna go up look at these soulless people they're ready
to eat my body they're ready to bum rush the stage they're
gonna they're ready to tear me limb from limb okay
Especially that guy over there.
It went up.
It went up a hole.
Oh my god.
The banker is like literally molding in the room.
The banker is cursing me out right now.
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I want to take it, but I don't.
In real life, I would take that.
Yeah, but this is a video game.
Look at him.
I want to see him still be salty.
Get your dollar.
I think the person who said they were from the future's
name, Josh.
No deal.
He's like, what's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you, solid sturd?
One case.
He's rage quitting.
24 or two a lot of people saying two a lot of people saying
24 I'm gonna go with two
I can't look open the case I can't look
uh-oh uh hey banker banker banker we can talk this out
banker okay banker okay he's laughing He's laughing at me.
No way.
There's no way I have the dollar.
Deal?
No deal!
I think I have the dollar.
It's fine.
I could have more than a dollar.
I could have 75 of them.
I'm not gonna listen to you guys.
Mint, what if your dollar is the dollar to surpass Metal
Gear?
No deal!
14?
Okay, we're gonna go with 14, you guys.
Open the case.
Open the case!
We have the dollar.
There's no way we don't have the dollar.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Here comes the offer.
Hello.
Okay.
I'll let him know.
Love you too.
Okay.
See you tonight.
The offer did go.
Or no deal.
He's rage quitting again.
Here's more money than what he's offering.
You guys, I'm not going to take it.
No deal.
the four show me one dollar we still have 750 thousand
dollars on the table we still have it we still have it i'm
gonna get rid of 24 because her hair is too yellow actually
she's very beautiful i'm not making fun of you christy
please don't have 750 000
Guys?
It's a miracle.
Here comes the offer.
Okay.
This guy is just like...
He's about to...
He's about to pounce on.
Oh my god.
If this was real life, I would be taking that.
Immediately, I would be taking that.
Oh, but it's not real life, you guys.
You guys, you guys, I'm so curious.
What's in mine?
1,000.
Sorry, Mr. Pugos.
Take the 50-50.
All in, baby.
He's literally, his head is on the...
Google the Monty Hall problem.
I do know it.
The Monty Hall problem.
Switching over, wait, switching over staying.
Mythbusters confirmed it.
Trust me when you want to switch.
So we do want to switch.
Should we swap cases?
You guys, it's a, it's a lot of, swap cases.
But we have four!
Believe in four.
Ride the four.
Believe in your case.
I know.
No swap!
Always swap.
Look at them!
Oh my gosh, we're all bouncing!
Oh my god, what is Howie doing?
You guys!
We should have swapped.
What's wrong with you?
What is this?
I got a donkey.
No deal, Mr. Banker.
Oh, refuse a banker.
banker's offer of at least 300,000.
What do they give me?
Call me a donkey friend.
Oh, stubborn as a mule.
That's so funny.
Yay, I got one million.
Just ignore, this is a comma.
One thousand.
Hey, a thousand dollars is a lot of money, okay?
So it's fine.
It's fine.
million play again play again mulligan
internally crying we should have switched i love how how it
was like believe in the a ruins just like you know that what
the monte hall problem you should switch do it hello and
welcome to deal or no deal i'm howie mandel hi howie oh gosh
Here they come.
Hi, Howie.
Here they come, guys.
Oh, oh, they're in gold this time.
Ooh.
Hi, Howie.
So terrified.
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, God.
Ooh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
Hi, Minto.
Why don't you guys ever greet me like that?
We got $26 million holding $26.
Hi, Minto.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money
placed there by a third party.
We don't know what's in what case, but we do know one case
is holding.
One case?
One million dollars.
Woo!
One million.
that case did you see that one howie mandel tick tock where
he showed a dude's butthole and asked if it was covid
related apparently lost sponsors because of it oh yes he
showed a prolapsed anus yes i do remember that i never saw
the video thank god but yes howie mandel posted a prolapsed
anus on tick tock i don't i don't know why he did it hi
minto hello oh i got boy i love that He what?
Yeah, that's what he did.
Actually, I don't even know what that means.
What is a prolapsed anus?
I just remember seeing people saying, don't look up Howie
Mandel's prolapsed anus.
I doubt!
Like the movie?
Hi, Minto.
The enemy becomes an Audi.
What number should we pick, everybody?
What number should we pick?
Should we pick the girl that looks like me?
Should we pick number nine who's looking off to the side?
I don't know where the... Oh, she's smiling now.
Okay, she noticed that we...
She broke the simulation for a second there.
Hi, Minto.
If I had...
And Nicol, for every time you talked about buttholes this
week, I would have more money than what's in case 15.
You know what?
We're going with case 15 then.
How much is in case 15?
Let's see.
This
week, I don't think that many is.
That's your case to keep, to take home, to spend, do
whatever you want.
To love, to marry, and sickness, and in health.
You ready?
Let's start by opening up six cases.
Six cases, baby.
I'm gonna pick one at random.
Nope.
Oh, it was number four.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Gayla!
Open a case.
Yay!
That could have been us, everybody.
That could have been us.
Gayla, our queen!
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ooh.
Five cases to open.
Good start, good start.
14.
Let's get the floors out of the way.
Perlapse is when an organ or bodily structure escapes the
muscles meant to keep it contained.
It doesn't have to be near an orifice.
What?
Oh, we're off the table already!
Oh my gosh, you guys, we're killing it.
What Snake's doing is happy dance.
Happy dance, happy dance.
All right, now 24.
Get the floors out of the way.
Oh, Christy.
Open the case.
Oh.
Christy, I'm sending you to jail for that.
Princess Gala, my beloved.
Yikes.
That was a really high one.
That was pretty bad.
Shame Case 4 has 1 million.
No, it doesn't.
I already opened it.
Still winnable.
Yeah, still winnable.
Number one.
Should we just go in order?
Minto case one cent.
No, it's not.
Open the case.
Kathleen.
Okay.
25.
The 25.
How many more do I have?
Oh, I have two more.
Two cases left open.
Case 10 will have under 1,000, I bet.
Okay, Keeley, so I'm going to believe you.
Case 10.
April.
That's not under 1,000.
That is exactly 1,000.
Not less.
100.
Profit.
I think Keeley, you need to go get some lottery numbers
today.
For real.
Ben.
Dang, Cole.
It was rounded up.
It was probably like 999, you know.
Number 18.
17, 19.
17?
I saw two 17s.
If you are still reading this, there's still time.
Oh, okay.
Oh, she's pumping the air.
We seem pretty satisfied with her.
17 was my pick for a case.
I mean, that's a pretty, that's a good, that's a lot of
money.
The man in this room with just one job, and it's a nasty
job, and his job is to get you out of here for as little as
possible.
He's looking at the board, he's looking at you, and he wants
to buy that case for as little as possible.
He's looking at me.
He's working it out.
That's the banker right there.
He's got a nasty job.
Ooh, he's nasty.
Oh, yeah, speaking nasty.
He's speaking nasty to Howie Mandel in his ear.
He's just like, yeah, you post that in as Howie Mandel.
Okay.
Yeah, he said okay.
He's speaking nasty words in his little ear.
He's whispering them.
The new offer?
No deal.
Deal or no deal?
No deal, no deal, no deal.
Yowie Mandel.
No way.
Low offer too soon.
Yeah, I think it's a, it'd be silly.
Unless we lost a million, you know.
12 is looking sus.
In a bad way or?
Wait, last time you guys said that it was really bad.
12 was just like, I have one penny.
I hope no one chooses me.
Dirty, nasty banker.
Four more cases.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I don't trust 19.
We go 20 now.
20.
Don't pick 21.
Not 13.
Okay.
Go with 11.
There's so many choices.
I don't know about you I'm feeling 22 How are we splitting
what's in your suitcase?
I mean what if it's a penny, you know I
was not feeling 22
Weird logarithm thank you for the thank you for the thank
you
You guys You guys!
Okay, we can still get 700.
Maybe we will take what the banker deals us.
If it's higher than 100,000.
Open the case.
75!
Thanks, Avery.
It's so old.
Berserk, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Two cases left open.
Don't give the banker the satisfaction.
open it you don't get the money basically you the rules of
the game is you pick one of these and then you eliminate the
rest and hopes that your case has the one million dollars hi
yeah 11 okay
they wouldn't put two big ones next to each other yeah
surely
five dollars
You want to get low numbers.
Leggy kick too.
19.
I like 19.
I think she's really cute.
I like her hair color a lot.
Jean.
Please, open the case.
Jolene.
$10!
Nice!
If only we...
This would be like the perfect game if we hadn't gotten rid
of the 1 million so early.
Oh gosh.
Here comes the offer.
Offer's gonna be so low.
Hello.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
See you tonight, Banker.
The new offer?
Ugh.
No way.
Deal or no deal.
Banker, you trying to put a fast one on me.
Huh?
No deal.
No way that we're gonna take that.
I know we lost the 1 million, but there's so many more
opportunities to get higher than that amount.
Like, come on.
64,000.
Four cases.
Siege, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
You guys.
You guys, what do I pick?
Seven.
You're...
Open the case.
Thank you, Dr. Connecticut.
Okay.
You know they don't need that long to tell the price over
the phone.
The banker is flirting with how he ever called.
Okay.
Three cases left.
Don't say ouch.
It's okay.
It's not that bad.
We're pleased.
We're okay.
25.
Two.
Lots of twos.
You.
Sydney.
Open the case.
Oh.
Oh, that one is not so great.
That's looking at my misery.
Stop collapsing.
Two cases left over.
Oh, wow.
I think I will go with 26.
You.
Elizabeth.
Open the case.
Okay.
Nice.
16 has the 500K.
How are you so sure?
Are you from the future?
One case.
I want to ask if you got my friend's gift, which was the
mint box from Offkai.
I haven't actually gotten the packages from Offkai yet.
They just shipped them, like, Yesterday or the day before.
I was there when he heard you wanted it and he freaked out
super hard.
Did you get my fan art letter postcard?
From Offkai?
I'll check once.
Oh, the stuff comes.
Okay, 5?
Do not pick 5.
13.
21's looking at me funny.
No, she's looking away.
She hurts you.
Maybe we go with 13.
13.
Amber.
Open the case.
What happened to the audience over there?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, good job.
Here comes the offer.
He sounds so excited.
He's like, here comes the offer.
Okay.
Right.
Yeah, that's what you're gonna do, Baker.
Okay.
All right.
What is it?
Just over.
Or no deal.
Just over 100,000.
Oh.
Oh, I don't know, guys.
Six figures looking pretty tasty.
I know.
But I think, I think I'm gonna do one more.
I'm gonna do no deal and I'm gonna do for one more.
No deal.
I bring it up.
We're gonna see it.
We can get it up higher.
We can get it up higher, I think.
I believe.
Three casings left over.
I believe, i believe, I believe.
Let's see.
How are we in the chat?
Twenty-one.
Okay.
All or nothing, Karen.
Open the case.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
5,000.
I wish it was one of the hundreds, but that's okay.
Not bad.
There's also the 50 still.
Two cases left open.
A
lot of people saying five.
Some people saying six.
Some people told me don't pick five.
I'm going to go with six.
I'm superstitious.
If you say don't open one, I'm scared to open it.
there you go oh we're dancing never mind it's good yippee i
i think
i don't i don't understand these people these are such high
numbers i don't understand they're such high numbers pick
five my lord
nine maybe we'll go with five afterwards please open the
case please oh this
is your doing If you have $50, I'll give you $50.
I'm holding you to that.
Roblox, oof.
Oof.
Ah, come on, Banker.
Banker, Banker, Banker.
No deal.
I won't do it, Banker.
I won't do it.
Are you sure you didn't go to a weird cold?
meeting with the soulless people watching.
I swear, they're ready to, like, suck my soul.
Two cases left over.
Two cases.
This man thinks of us as a fool.
Yeah, thinks us a fool.
Five or 23.
I like how we're glowing.
Gonna go with 23.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please, please.
Oh!
This is your fault!
You guys told me 23!
One case.
Okay, I'm gonna go with five.
At this point, risk it for the biscuit.
Open the case.
Open the guys.
There you go.
Hey!
Why are they clapping?
Because they feel sorry for him.
They feel sorry for me.
If I have the $50...
What do you think is going to happen?
I'll go donate $50 to somebody.
I'll go donate $50 to a random YouTuber.
Really?
What do you mean by that?
The offer did go.
117.
Deal or no deal?
So we still have 750, 200, 100.
50, 400, 750.
It's basically 50-50 to get more money.
Well, I mean, 100k is not more, but it's like close enough
maybe.
One third to do better.
It's so tempting to just say no deal every time.
Suddenly K is 15 just manifested 50k.
One more case.
It's a horror film.
It's a horror.
This game is a horror game.
Truly.
16.
The one that looks like Minto.
Melanie.
Melanie Minto.
You guys, I think we're walking out pretty, um, that's so
good.
What do you think is going to happen?
I think we're walking out not so good.
Hello.
Okay.
Right.
It's going to go down.
It's going to go down for sure.
The offer went down.
Yeah.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no deal.
No deal.
I wonder if the audience has any different expressions.
Eight?
Okay, I'm seeing everybody say eight.
I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you guys so much.
Open the case.
I'm trusting you guys.
I trusted you guys.
I
can't even afford shoes at this rate.
I can't afford anything.
It's going to go down, Howie.
Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
Hello.
What do you mean?
What do you think is going to happen?
Okay.
the audience is smiling while I'm suffering look at them
they're just wait did that go up or am I crazy deal or no
deal no okay it went down now deal at this rate at this rate
we're just gonna we're just gonna um the odds are really
against us but you know Extremely against us.
One case.
But you know, I'm gonna do 25.
750 or bust, baby.
Open the case.
Okay.
There's hope.
A new hope.
What do you think's gonna happen?
Howie, howie, howie.
I'm not writing this fan fiction.
He's like wanting me to continue.
Okay.
He's mauling again.
He's like, please.
Just take the money.
You guys.
Deal or no deal.
I think I need to take this.
I think I need to take it.
But for the content.
It's so...
It's such a good deal.
But I'm not a smart person.
I believe in case 15!
One case.
18 or 20 you guys.
18?
20?
I'm just gonna close my eyes and pick one.
Oh, wait.
I can't see.
I'm trying to feel it with my...
20.
Open the case.
Guys!
What do we do?
It's going to go up, Howie.
It's going to go up.
It's going to go away.
up hello oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god what do we
do what do we do swap swap swap it went up only an idiot
would not take this oh my god but oh my god only an idiot
would not take this only an idiot but i'm not gonna take it
we can get the 700 we can get The 700, we could get the 700,
we could
get...
Oh my god, Nano, your case had 750,000.
We went from 750,000 to 750,000.
What happened to believing in case 15?
But you guys told me to switch.
You're here, buddy.
My stomach hurts.
Oh god, I think I'm going to throw up.
Oh my god.
No, I'm never gambling ever in my life.
I'm never gambling in life.
Wait, what did Nano say earlier too?
It was just like...
Oh, wasn't it like I'll pay you more than what's in the case
or something?
Um, hey, pay up, buddy.
You were
the luckiest person for 24 rounds to throw it all the way on
the 25th.
I can't.
I can't right now.
1,800 gambler.
It's a bit about the Monty Hall problem.
It only applies if the dealer chooses the door that opens.
So in this, it's just 50-50.
Oh my god.
We got this, guys.
We got this.
Don't do it!
Thank you for that.
You had a really good pick, man.
You picked a really good game.
Oh my god, betting $2 off Minto will be forever broke.
So far we have made $1,700.
They
like match my ribbons.
They match my ribbons.
Thank you guys, thank you for the fake.
Hello ladies.
Hi Howie.
Oh my god.
Ooh, I love that.
Let's say hello to our next player.
The way they all don't blink.
Nobody in this game blinks.
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money.
placed there by a third party.
Oh, Howie blinks.
We don't know what's in what case.
But we do know one case is holding one million dollars.
I'm gonna get it.
All the way down to one penny.
I'm gonna get the million all the way down to one penny.
That's not gonna be me.
Pick a case.
I love how you went from wanting to walk away to shouting no
deal.
I'm all in, baby.
I didn't realize that he made it interesting.
Like, come in and die again.
13?
16 again?
We never picked 16 to begin with.
You're all out here looking like Chibi Titans.
I don't know about you.
No, they wouldn't put 20.
They wouldn't put the million in 22 again.
Forever 17!
I could only afford to pay for one blinking animation.
Ooh, Veronica!
That's your case to keep, to take home, to love and to hold,
to cherish.
Unless you should decide to sell it.
I'm not gonna sell it!
You ready?
Not this, I'm not gonna sell it.
Let's start by opening up six cases.
I'm not gonna sell it.
Gone.
You know what comes after 17?
Never 18.
11?
Let's go 11.
You.
Abbey.
Open the case.
About 17 will be the 1 million case.
5,000, okay, nice, nice.
Never go to Vegas, please.
Not real money.
It's fine.
Let's open up five more cases.
Five more cases, okay.
I'm just gonna guess.
I'm gonna randomly pick one.
Wait, okay, hold on.
I gotta land on one.
Where'd my mouse go?
Okay, here.
Hot.
Seven!
Open the case.
We're happy.
We're cheap.
cheering.
We're cheering.
Four more cases.
It could be worse.
Yeah, let's go with Gaila.
Yeah, wrong side of the board.
Come on, Gaila.
Gaila.
Yeah!
Oh, she's so cute.
Yippee!
I love when Snake dances.
Okay, three cases left.
Take the first deal offward.
It's going to be so low.
Let's do...
Number six.
Hannah.
Open the case.
Bad.
This is just bad.
guys this is just bad this is just bad this is not a good
run we might just take the i don't know about you ha oh wait
did i click 22 right 22 21 please open the case uh-oh okay
it's irrelevant you have the one million
Okay, okay.
One case.
Time to avoid 22.
Yeah, God just told me not to pick it.
Okay, first number I see.
17 has the million.
Nine.
I saw nine.
You.
Emily.
Open the case.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're going to do a little dance.
Yippee!
There's a man in this room with just one job.
One job?
A nasty job.
His job is to get you out of here for as little as possible.
Nasty, nasty man up there.
Why are you so nasty, banker?
He's going to call me and make you an offer right now.
IRL Eeyore.
Thank you for the birthday gift.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Dirty, nasty man.
His whisper is dirty, nasty things in my ear.
percentages fractions oh I kind of want to take it but it's
so bad what should we do guys no deal we'll go with a
hundred thousand deal there's
always the what if that makes me want to just push forward
you You know what I'm saying?
There's always the what if.
That's jump change.
You're so right.
I doubt it.
Matthew, don't doubt me.
25.
Lulzie, it better not be $1 million or else.
I'm going to be...
AHHHHH!
Losey.
Losey, why?
Four cases.
Banned.
It was not a million, that's true.
Pick number three, my lord.
I'm gonna go with two.
Open the case.
Ah!
75 and you've said we'll go with 1,000 every single time and
you know yeah but we've gotten as high as 400,000 we can do
it again we can get 400,000 please pick case three okay I'm
stealing all your life for so we'll see if he's still
welcome to my ocean
yeah yeah yeah yeah wow the right side is looking awfully
dark two cases left is looking not so great for us you guys
that's what every gambler addict says that's why I'm not in
Vegas baby I'm feeling 20 in my jellies 10 15 8 for 500
dollars 500 loss statistics don't lie go 15 the math works
okay james cavern i'm believing in you 15 15 15 15 15 15
one more case
still got the million 13.
I have a bad feeling about this.
Open the case.
Never mind!
We still have like all the lowest numbers though.
Every single one of them.
James Cameron, how could you do that to me?
James Cameron!
What do you think is going to happen?
That would have changed my afterlife.
How long?
I don't know why you do that to me huh right I went down it
went down or sad face or no deal don't let it go down
what an insulting offer I know right we still have the 1
million on the board
I wonder how like like statistically how easy it is to get
like super low numbers like what is the lowest offer he can
give us i wonder let's see 18 i'm not feeling 22 jimmy you
take that back open the case 22 is a nice nice nice hundred
hundred hundred from
what i remember about 40 cents no way 26 please okay I see
two people saying 26 skeptical panda welcome back thank you
open the case 26 26 yeah I can't even look anymore I can't
even look this is stressing me out do all the girls also
have the same eye color are they literally just copied and
pasted I think they all have the same eye color.
Sailor move for a turtle!
Thanks for doing that.
Thank you.
Guys, what do I do?
Number one?
Oh, God.
I don't know about this one.
I'm not feeling it.
Open the case.
I told you all.
Not number one.
I told you!
Let's Let's go for a low score.
You know what?
Yeah, we still have all the lowest numbers.
Let's go for a super duper low score.
Okay, then what we're going to do is go with 22 since I was
protected from picking that one before.
Open the case.
700, 700.
What do you think is going to happen?
I don't know.
It's going to go down.
It's going to go even more down.
Okay.
okay 750 for what versus one cent for the how are you feel
are you feeling it now mr.
crabs oh come on wait what was the previous one deal or no
it went up a little tiny it's like $2,000 it went up like
2,000 less than less than 1,900 that a contestant on a uk
show was once offered zero pounds and 12 eggs what you have
750 again don't swap no deal like they were rubbing our
hands we're just like i don't know man oh oh we're thinking
i know our odds are looking really bad but come on three
cases left open What should I pick?
Trust me this time, pick eight.
Okay!
We're trusting Losey one more time.
Audrey.
There's our scent!
It's not enough money for her kids in the home.
Cute?
Are you okay?
One scent!
We finally got one of the low numbers.
out no okay yeah now we won't get the lowest offer ten let's
go with ten I want to get the million I want to get the
million 500 I mean obviously we're not getting at this game
but I want the million it will happen
One more case.
One more.
12?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
I like her.
Can't remember her name.
Jan.
I'll be your case.
10.
Okay, surely our offer will go up now.
A little, maybe.
I think.
Hello,
everybody.
What do you think is going to happen?
Bye.
Thanks for the raid.
We're playing deal or no deal, and it's really intense.
It's like crazy.
Bring back thanks for the gift.
AKSTF2, thanks for the 550.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
It went up.
Oh, come on.
This banker, I'm literally, I'm going to attack you.
I'm going to find you.
He's molding.
Why are you molding back there?
Murphy, thanks for the gift in.
Why are you molding in here?
You're acting like this is, I mean, it is a lot.
of money but like comparatively speaking it's not that much
pyro bug thanks for the boy gifted Tobias thanks for the
gifted donkey thanks for the gifted that is a lot of money I
know but he has offered me four hundred thousand dollars
before two cases left open okay guys Leah if you're still
here do you want to pick my next case if you're still here
Leah If not, I see people saying five.
S1!
Thank you for the good thing you did.
Thank you so much.
This guy is heavy breathing in my ear.
Okay.
Number five.
I'm shaking.
I'm shaking, you guys.
I was shaking.
Okay.
We'll go with five.
I redeemed myself.
Yes, you did.
Thank you.
Joy, thank you for the face.
Don't clap.
Stop clapping.
Don't say nice.
23 is low on trust.
23.
You.
Teresa.
Come on, come on.
Oh.
Yeah, guys, I think it's Jover.
Dollar, I think we only have a dollar.
Here comes the offer.
Hello.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
The offer's going down.
The new offer?
Come on.
We could have the 750.
deal no deal no deal i trust i trust i trust i trust i trust
we'll get an achievement for winning more than seven hundred
thousand dollars one case take these deals seriously game i
know right One case.
We stand case 17.
20.
12.
Let's go with 16.
Miss Mint Phantom.
Phantom.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, dollars!
I think we have the dollars.
I think we have the doll.
Here comes the offer.
Look at us with our hands on our hips.
Okay.
Hello.
Yeah.
Right.
He's like, make him take this deal.
Deal or no deal.
What's so frustrating about it is it's always when it comes
down to like the final five that he makes like a good off a
decent offer you know one more let's go one more one more
one more one more one more one more one more one more i
can't stop i can't stop this one more one more one more case
one more case
20 has one dollar trust trust 20 has one dollar 14 is so
lonely yeah because she has the 750k open your case open
your case so
average of a of a of a number to get rid of.
It's not bad.
It's not good, though.
It's just kind of, you know.
What do you think's going to happen?
I don't know, actually, Howie.
Hello.
Okay.
I'm not so invested in your relationship with a banker.
Oh, okay.
I am just...
He sounded so disappointed.
It went up.
Ah!
Deal or no deal?
Oh, my God, you guys.
Only an idiot wouldn't take this.
One more?
Should we do one more?
We always have the 750,000 left.
It's crazy.
You got one more in you.
One more!
Gamble, gamble, he's malding, he's malding.
14.
I think 14 is not a good one.
I think I'm going to go with 12.
Open your case.
Hey!
Oh my god, the offer is going to be insane, you guys.
I
think we have a dollar, Howie.
I think we have a dollar in my 17 case.
Okay.
The banker is mulling.
The new offer?
What?
I'm sorry.
Didn't even go up.
I thought it was going to go up to like 400,000.
Wait, it went down.
Why did the offer go down?
Excuse me.
no deal mr banker why did it go down yeah it went lower by
like a couple thousand
insulted they know no deal
it's because i have a dollar isn't it
one case
you guys you guys you guys you guys open
What do you think's gonna happen?
Okay.
We have a dollar, we have one dollar.
We have one dollar went down.
Oh my god, it went down so much.
Where Snake looks so sad.
No, I'm taking home my dollar, man.
I'm taking that home with pride.
A dollar with pride.
We're such an idiot.
The snake is so dumb.
$1 in a dream, baby!
You want to switch cases?
No swap!
Give me my dollar.
Here it comes!
What?!
We didn't even get the dollar!
We didn't...
I am not...
Doomed if you do, doomed if you don't.
This sucks so much.
Oh my god.
Another $750.
A dollar and a dream.
This somehow feels like a bigger L than if you...
I know I wanted the dollar.
Here's more money than you want in the game.
never going to vegas i it's the desire sensor so true like
you guys are all the dollars you might be disappointment you
might be a disappointment but you're our disappointment oh
gosh i can't believe it this chat isn't even worth one
dollar oh man okay this time one million if we don't get the
million we're taking the bankers deal real real real real
ladies please oh my god had Leah's viewers seen this yet
this part is so scary oh they're in red now oh god here they
come the la les It's the genome soldiers.
Hi, Howie.
Mint's a great gambler.
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, I love that.
That's so good.
Thank you for the fight.
Thank you.
Hi, Howie.
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money
placed there by Do you think he recorded these for the game
or they took them from the TV show?
I like the red dresses though.
Like the person that's breathing.
Pick a case.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know how to pick.
Hi, Minto.
Case 3.
16.
13 is the million.
Because I'm very sure about that.
Case number one had the one million last time, so I don't
think it's this time again.
You know?
Case eight.
Seems kind of safe, right?
Eight?
I think we're gonna go with nine.
I think I'm feeling nine.
Yippee!
Soulless people jumping in the audience.
Nice.
That's your case to keep, to take home, to love, to cherish.
Unless you should decide to sell it.
I won't.
Don't...
Let's find out if you got a million dollars in there.
You ready?
There is one million dollars in there, Howie.
Let's start by opening up six cases.
I'm gonna pick number 12!
Oh, oh, there's a bug.
There's a bug, there's a bug.
Ah!
No!
Oh, okay, we're safe.
Baka baka
The bug saved us There's a bug in here though Oh my god go
away Okay Five more cases What do you guys think?
What do you guys think?
Hundred bucks down baby Welcome back Thank you Calvin Five?
Okay five Five Mm-hmm.
Yo.
Camille.
Open the case.
I heard the look on her face like, ooh.
Look on her face just being like, ooh.
What if I just go in order?
What if I count down from 26 and just go down?
Whoever, two people that said five.
What were you thinking?
50!
It's not bad.
Do it.
All right, next we're gonna count down.
We're gonna count down.
Okay, three cases left over.
25.
Wow.
Open the case.
Come on, Alexis.
We were doing so well.
Safe to pick four and six because five is a big number.
I don't think that's how that works, but we can test it out.
Let's do four.
Let's pick Gayla.
And then we'll do six.
Open the case.
One penny.
Gayla, our girl.
We almost picked that case.
Also, is Howie supposed to be blonde?
Because his eyebrows are blonde, but his goatee is like
brown.
One case.
but he is bald so i don't know what to believe does he die
his goatee or does he does he bleach his eyebrows i don't
know all right six hannah open the case hannah has always
done me dirty though i'm telling you be dirty she
looks so apologetic in the background there's a man in this
room with just one job a nasty job oh Oh, it is a nasty
joke.
He shaves his head?
Hair and beard colors can be naturally different.
He's going to call me and make you an offer right now.
That's going to be a really bad offer.
It's going to be such a bad offer.
Joy, thank you for the 15.
Enjoy your Doom 64.
Do you plan to play Doom Dark Ages?
I'd like to.
Once it comes out, yeah.
Maybe.
So different from the old school Doom song.
A new offer?
No, as long as the million dollars As long as the million
dollars is still up for grabs, you guys We're not taking the
deal But once the million is gone, then maybe we should take
the deal The million is still out there Oh no, the odds are
kind of against us right now But
The deals are going to get worse and worse Go with one.
If this has one million dollars in it, I think I'm just
gonna jump out this window.
Open the case.
Okay.
Alright, Kathy.
Okay, Kathy.
I have a ginger beard and blonde hair, so I attest.
You have a beard!
My eyebrows are dirty, blonde, and my beard is jet black.
How did you grow that?
here we go starting to think that in life can't deal well
luckily I'm in the after life yeah baby
we're shuffling we're shuffling dancing we're so happy even
though it's a lot of stuff from the right side of the board
but that's okay three cases left open number three baby
number three baby open the case yeah it's
nice 500k no two cases left over two more cases what should
we pick what should we pick what should we pick what should
we pick 22 has 1 million for sure no i have 1 million
23 23 23.
Mine has mint a zillion dollars.
Open your case.
Yeah!
And still on the board.
One million still on the board.
One case.
Okay.
You guys.
what should we do
look at the scary people in the back oh god howie he's like
sniffing me howie you're too close what are you doing there
howie 12 okay we'll go with 12 12 has to go sarah open the
case Yeah!
Okay.
Maybe we'll get an okay offer this time.
We got rid of some low ones.
Would love a...
Who wants to be a millionaire stream?
Or collab sometime in the future.
I would love to do that too.
I actually owned that for the PlayStation when I was a kid.
Who wants to be a millionaire.
Okay.
Yeah.
Give it to me straight.
offer is it terminal what the hell me blonde my brother
brother brunette and my father all have different hair
colors but all of our beards are red why do you all have
beards
they're still oh do shio do shio
rock boss thanks for the dollar howie i'm a wisp not a
mathematician no Red beard y'all.
Red beard y'all.
Mint where is your beard?
I'm working on it.
17?
I've seen several people say 17.
I think this one has the million.
This one has the million.
500.
Half a million.
50,000.
Okay, three cases left over.
I'm a mint, not a mathematician.
I'm not a mint mathematician.
I'm a mint...
I'm a mint mathematician!
14!
Yo!
Open the case.
Nice!
Two cases left.
What do you say, guys?
What do you say?
What do we say?
One dollar still on the table.
Oh my god, you're right.
Oh, 19.
Yes, we love Junyun.
Yes.
Open the case.
Come on!
We're fine.
He's clapping.
Those are some aggressive claps.
He's like, we're okay.
We're okay.
Still one million on the board.
Seven.
Lina.
Oh, I accidentally skipped it.
I love when he does that.
Our deal is going to be so bad.
the bankers gonna lowball us so much okay okay okay the new
offer
deal or no deal it could be better or i mean it could be
worse
i think i'm gonna take it i think i'm gonna take it you guys
i want the million We'll do another game.
We got lowballed so much.
What was in our case?
Is it a dollar?
We're waiting.
But
I can't read it.
It's all two pixels.
This is happening to me.
I'm never going on this TV show.
Your luck is so weird.
Welcome to my afterlife.
This is just the mint away.
Alright, this is the one million dollars!
This is it, this is it!
One million, one million, one million, one million, one
million, one million, one million!
You're the best gambler ever.
Vegas loves me.
Vegas would truly love me But I was interested to see what
happens If you choose the deal, you know Ladies, please
Ladies, please
Scream came from somewhere dark in front Purple Will those
hips don't not lie I'm never seen anyone so bad, Kim Stop
Why you guys make me feel so bad bad about myself.
Here it is.
Hi ladies.
Hello ladies.
Oh I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
They're like haven't you been on this show like 50 times?
Our earnings don't even add up to like a hundred thousand.
Our earnings are so bad you guys like a total earnings one
million one
pick a case we're good to pick a case
hi minto snake makes the ratings go wild
guy giving up before taking time is being here
Lucky seven.
No, it just had the million.
So it won't have it again.
But maybe number eight will have it.
Wait, didn't we?
No, we picked nine before.
And seven had it.
It's got to be eight.
It's got to be the middle of the three of them.
Audra, I'm taking your box.
Get off the screen.
case to keep to take home to spend do whatever you want
unless you should decide to sell it no let's find out i
don't know you ready let's start by opening up six cases
okay let's start i should have picked number six six always
you know what i'm gonna start with six because six always
has a high number if it has one million i'm literally giving
up hannah
see i'm telling you it always has a high We're making all of
us who lost our Firefly 50-50s feel better, so thanks for
that, Meantime.
You should go to Vegas with Matara and have you do all the
killing for her.
Every time, six of such a high number!
Oh.
Every time.
Hannah's out to get us, man.
Let's go with 19.
Okay.
Open the case.
Five dollars!
Perhaps you should have picked case six.
No, no, because that's not one million.
That's not one million.
But maybe we will pick it next time.
Okay.
Four cases.
Number 12.
I'm gonna do it, maybe you do it by rows, right?
Okay.
Open the case.
Open the case, Sarah.
The penny!
We're dancing, we're dancing, we're dancing, we're dancing,
we're dancing,
we're dancing.
Very nice.
Okay, three cases left over.
You guys.
26?
All right, Fernando says 26.
Please, Elizabeth.
Open the case.
Elizabeth.
Oh.
Two cases left open.
I am so sorry.
Open the case.
Ooh, choo-choo.
Okay.
We have one more, I think, right?
One more case.
Eleven, baby.
Okay.
Let's go for 11.
Oh my god, we are so bowed.
We are so bowed.
Does he have a giant nasty job?
It's a nasty job.
I feel like I'm reliving the same day over and over and over
again.
He's working it out.
That's the banker right there.
The banker right there.
an offer right now okay oh it's what do you think is gonna
happen i think i'm gonna get a shit offer howie okay hello
okay okay howie howie howie do you grow hair they had to
animate even they even put his like his neck folds on the
back of his head put that on his model no deal Do I ever
accept the deal?
Just like Bill Murray, but you're not learning.
What are you talking about?
It's different every day!
Oh.
Leave Howie alone.
That guy posts butts on the internet, so...
Chum, chum, chum, endless eight dollars.
Three zeros starting after life broke.
One for one dollar.
Yupers.
Four more cases.
Groundhog deal.
You know what, since we just got 400?
Sorry.
I will pick four.
Open the case.
Open the case, Gail.
lot yeah
nice 21 okay we'll go for 21 next okay three cases left i
don't know about you but it's not 22 oh wait open the case
come on come on come on oh my god yeah we're jiving
we're grooving i hope i get a dollar i want one dollar cases
left open one dollar one dollar one dollar one dollar one
dollar take your luck I had a shotgun see what happens care
to try buckshot roulette I've actually been interested in
trying that but I thought I think I saw that it was like a
pretty short game right 25 25 oh I almost clicked 24 25
Open the case.
Come on, Alexis.
Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Number 15.
One more case.
One million dollars.
This is it.
Amy.
Open the case.
One dollar!
Okay.
It's good for a short stream.
What do you think is going to happen?
oh gosh hello yeah okay okay okay you nasty nasty man okay
dirty okay okay oh 71 but we still have one million on the
board everybody we still have one million on the board one
million on the i mean we have a lot of like 10 and 75 how
many is there four five six seven One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Oh, wait, we actually have eight on the right side and seven
on the left side.
No deal.
The odds are in my favor.
With mince luck, backshot roulette.
Oh, not backshot.
Buckshot.
Sorry.
Isn't that something else?
A backshot?
Just get to six figures.
I'm trying.
Buckshot roulette will be short.
No, I won't.
I'm going to go for 17.
Yep.
Open the case.
300!
Very nice.
Yippee!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Yep.
Open the case.
Ah, nine.
It's not great.
Wait, didn't we pick, no, we picked eight, right?
Okay, we'll do nine next.
Two cases left open.
Nine, nine.
Nine.
Emily.
Open the case.
500!
Okay.
Yeah, there's no way 7 has the million this time.
You're so right.
You're right.
I can't press it.
I'm shaking too much.
Wait, the AI summary is about what?
Your pelvic thrusting now?
Was that the last one?
Yep.
What do you think is going to happen?
Hello.
Okay.
It's funny because one of my friends was just like...
The new opera?
Was like, I think you might need to start thinking about an
18 plus 10.
Deal?
Or no?
On Twitter.
So, um, I think I'll probably add one.
I didn't know what an un-birther was, okay?
No deal!
No deal on this!
Okay, three cases left over.
Okay.
What does this mean down here?
The little... the little dot.
But also he said like there's sometimes you can get like a
million dollar offer some like minigame or something.
So...
Okay.
People have already started using mating press.
Why are you making up your own tags?
I haven't even put... I haven't even told you what it is.
Oh, it's the player on the Wii!
Oh, it's the Wii mode.
You're right!
You're so right.
I thought it was part...
Can this game be multiplayer?
It doesn't seem very fair.
Okay, number 23.
Yeah.
Come on, guys, we got this.
Open the case.
10!
Yeah!
Our offer's gonna shoot up, man.
Our offer's gonna shoot to the stars.
Yappy!
Okay.
Two cases left over.
10 has $10.
for we just got rid of the ten dollars you can't say that
akiyama you can't say that if possible we should do one of
the custom games yeah i want to try i want to try but i
really want to win the million dollar 20 okay let's do 20.
a lot of people are saying 20 but if it's if it's bad i'm
gonna be really sad you guys i'm not even gonna i'm not
gonna look
okay half one case oh my god the bug is back it's like a
little nat in my room i hate summer because all the gnats
come out three i don't know i feel like three is the one
million april open the case
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god this is a really good run it is it is our luck has
turned around so much what do you think is gonna happen
Super good deal.
The banker is malding up there.
Okay.
The offer did go.
But we're not going to deal.
You guys, we still have 500, 750, and 1 million on the
board.
Like, we are killing it right now.
No deal.
Okay.
Now there!
Two cases left open.
Two cases.
We have 75 and 200.
1,000, 10,000.
100,500, 750, 1 million.
Why are your eyebrows so thick?
No, it's a headband.
It's solid snake.
Number 10.
I'm scared.
so scared okay 10,000 okay okay okay remember this game
started so bad with the 200 300 400 but now we're like okay
I'm thinking 18 I'm thinking 18 10 for 10k open the case
open the case oh we
already have a call here comes the offer here comes the
offer oh howie I'm scared yeah yeah okay talk dirty to me
banker okay I mean nasty to me the offer went down oh down
no deal I still have one million on the board mr.
no I'm not even gonna let you finish your sentence no
deal no deal no deal no deal we got to get rid of the 75 and
200, though.
Alright, guys.
What do we pick?
13?
I started watching YouTubers with you and Matara.
Thank you!
Now I am a HENYA simp too.
We got this next deal.
I'm also a HENYA simp.
There's also 14.
I'm going to go with 13.
Please, please, please.
Open the case.
The offer went up.
What do you think is going to happen?
It's going to go up.
The banker is so salty right now.
Hello.
He's like screaming.
Okay.
Oh, he's not.
Oh, okay.
Actually, he's not so salty.
Not yet.
The offer did go.
It did?
We still haven't reached 400,000, though.
No deal.
You can't make me.
You can't make me not with that million dollars still stuck
up there on the board.
Okay, I'm gonna go with 14 then.
I'm gonna go with 14, you guys.
Oh!
Open the case.
Guys?
What do you think is going to happen?
Okay.
It went up.
Of course it did.
Whoa!
Oh, shoot.
I want to take it so bad.
Deal or no deal.
I want to take the deal so bad.
Yeah, next move will make or break for you?
real we still have the one million though and i said as long
as they're still one million on the board it is no deal baby
no deal one more case oh my god oh my god
guys so guys so guys you guys you guys you guys you guys
the stress of it all.
I don't know about you.
I'm scared of 22.
But it wasn't 1 million.
It wasn't 1 million.
It went down, but it...
I love your streams.
Thank you, Marcus.
Thank you so much for a super chat.
What do you think is going to happen?
Hello.
okay okay okay right yeah okay went down quite a bit no deal
I will take the L before I take the offer nasty
banker oh my god oh my god you guys my anxiety is so high
right now i don't know 16 or 24 what am i doing oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god i can't look open the
case What do you think is going to happen?
Hello.
Okay.
What do I do?
The offer is going to be insane.
It's actually going to...
The offer is going to...
Oh my god, it's actually insane.
No deal.
Deal?
No deal!
Oh my god.
Did I actually pick the $1 million?
case there's no way there's no way there's no way did i pick
the one million dollar case you guys you guys you guys you
guys you want to switch cases oh my god no swap no swap
we're doubling down i I believe in case eight!
I believe!
Please, please!
It was right there in front of me.
It was...
It was right there.
In front of me.
One.
What's the closest we'll ever get?
Hold on, my YouTube just froze.
I can't read the chat.
You guys!
You!
One second, oh gosh.
Hold on, because I'm...
Hold on, I have to change my screen a little bit around.
You guys, we were so close to the $1 million.
We were so close!
It was right there.
It was my lucky number.
No one's rooting for me.
Let's change the settings.
We got so close there.
We got actually so close that I'm like...
Oh my gosh.
That was like probably the best game I'll ever have ever.
I've never seen anyone so sad about winning 100k.
I know, but when it was that compared to 1 million...
We need to add a pity system to this game.
I thought they also said, I feel like if the 1 million is on
the board.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, my goodness.
Wait, hold on.
Ladies, please.
Wait.
No, ladies.
I didn't want to do another game.
I wanted to change the setting.
Seeing your luck with money, I wanted to send you this pity
super chat.
Thank you, Takedo.
Oh, green.
Oh, my God.
You can really see their cleavage.
this time hello
ladies hi oh i love that please say hello to our next player
get me out of here pick a case no wait how do i actually
leave how do i leave there's how do i oh here we go okay
quit quit i want to change the settings guys let's see maybe
custom game what kind of custom is it special event oh
include mini games yes million dollar mission two wait seven
million dollar mission uh choose the number of million
dollar cases
my luck can't be that bad right higher top value double
dollar value double or nothing random
Two players.
Uh-oh, we're going against the CPU, you guys.
I'm kind of scared.
Wait.
The CPU is probably going to win, right?
Cheating ghosts!
What they allowed me to!
How does this game have multiplayer?
I have no idea.
Hey.
Hello and welcome to Deal or No Deal.
I'm Howie Mandel.
Hi, Howie Mandel.
Today is a special, special episode.
Ladies, please.
The board.
What color?
Just like my ribbon!
Yes.
I'll cheer for CPU.
Why do you hate me?
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
It's me.
And...
CPU?
What?
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Wait, where's CPU?
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money
placed there by a third party.
We don't know what's in what case.
But we do know one case is holding $1 million.
I thought he was gonna say 13 cases.
Oh!
laugh if it ends up with a penny i will go with whatever is
in my case you guys i am not i will go with whatever is in
my case okay i basically have a 50 50 chance of i will i
will i will not back down if i lose the million i lose the
million and we're going with number four i think maybe
actually i don't know i pounded at the math it's not monte
hall it's actually 50 50 so might as swap anyway unless you
lose it yeah actually I'm gonna make it random I'm gonna
close my eyes and if you close your eyes I almost feel one
million dollars number 11 Abby bomb Abby that's your case to
keep to take home to spend do whatever you want unless you
should decide to sell it.
Let's find out if you got a million dollars in there.
Yeah, every time I swap, it's bad.
And every time I don't swap, it's bad.
All right, we're gonna start with number four, lucky number
four.
Here we go, baby.
Open the case.
We're picking Galen out.
25.
Oh, we're grooving.
Oh, we're schmoving.
You guys, this is a true test of my luck.
Five cases to open.
13.
Lucky number 13.
Actually, I should go for six because they always screw me
over.
Open the case.
400!
You guys, are we killing it or what?
I think we're doing really awesome.
I don't understand what the game mode is, though.
It seems the exact same.
Number six has one million in it.
I need you to get Howie Mandel the guest on Star Astrid.
Open the case.
I don't think so.
What?
You guys, how is this possible?
Okay, three cases left open.
Guys, how is this possible?
Okay, you pick the next one.
You pick the next one.
Nine, I saw nine first by turtles.
You.
Open the case.
Our first one million down.
Two cases left open.
Suspiciously, we're gonna go for number one.
17.
Okay, we'll go number 17 next.
Sorry.
No, turtles.
It's all good.
One more case.
All right.
Someone said.
Thank you for the pink, though.
You didn't have to do that.
Here we go.
Veronica.
It's okay.
We have nine.
We have nine left.
It's okay.
Oh, it's okay.
Oh, 10 left.
Three in a row.
And in this room with just one job.
And it's a nasty job and his job is to get you out of here
for as little as possible He's looking at the board.
He's looking at you and he wants to buy that you guys do you
think I have a million in my case That's the banker right
there.
He's gonna call me and make you an offer right now.
Do you think I have one million in my case right now?
What do you think's gonna happen?
Hello, okay Right Surely you could get 13 in a row New
offer.
Wowie!
This is the highest offer I think we'll ever get in the
first time.
Deal or no deal?
No deal.
There's still a million on the board, obviously.
I have one cent.
If I have a single penny in my case, I will go Akasupa
someone right now.
Actually, quick idea, I'd love to see Mint play as the
banker.
That'd be so fun.
25.
Open your case.
Come on, Alexis.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Four more cases.
I think I will cry if I actually lose this because this is
just a testament of my life, my afterlife.
everything, my entire being, when I was alive.
Fuck it out!
Getting them out, like, talk
to you guys.
I think I'm gonna...
I think I'm gonna worry.
I think I'm worried, you guys.
I think I'm worried.
Oh, no.
Like...
Open the case.
This is the next level.
two
cases left over
pick number 10 okay you guys are better open the case
that wasn't me that was you guys
my stomach hurts please the higher
you for anti-gambling oh god My stomach hurts.
I don't know about you.
I'm feeling 22.
Oh, please.
Open the case.
We broke the streak.
Oh, my goodness.
If it was another million, I don't know what
I'm...
I'm still scared.
Our offer is gonna be such dog shit, you guys.
Okay.
Oh, God.
The offer went down.
Of course it did.
But we still have a million on the board.
It's the best worst luck ever.
This isn't like, if anyone is ever just like, man.
Mint is not very lucky.
This is just a testament to my luck, okay?
I have negative luck stat.
Oh, gosh.
I'm going to go with three.
Oh, just like you, my goal.
Let's go.
All right.
Open the case.
Please open the case.
200.
I just want to win with one million.
We're sticking with our 11, though.
We're sticking with 11.
I'm going to go with two.
I know Min's trying to buy more Metal Gear merch.
You need to win that, Millie.
Open the case.
It's okay.
There's still a couple left.
That's all right.
There's still 5 million left.
No worries.
Two cases left over.
I'm gonna go with five.
Let's just knock out the entire first row.
Let's just take it out.
Come here.
100 if we have a dollar oh god okay okay i know you guys are
rooting for my downfall but please i'm gonna go for 20.
open the case 300 okay our offer might even go up That
wasn't so bad.
That
wasn't...
We're rooting for CPU.
Where is that guy?
Here comes the offer.
Here come.
What if he was in the audience, like, staring?
Hello.
Okay.
Yeah.
It went up.
Nice.
But I believe in number 11.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, golly, what do I do?
Oh, I don't know.
Down you.
Okay, three cases left, though.
Three cases left.
Good night.
Good luck, Minto.
Thanks, Jesse.
26.
Open the case.
The dollar is out, you guys.
The dollar is out.
Who would have thought it would be this hard to get one
really?
Two cases left over.
I'm going to get rid of the second row as well.
Open the case.
500.
Our deal is going to go up.
Our deal is going to go way up.
One case.
Number eight.
Okay.
One case.
number eight.
75!
I can't even imagine what our offer is going to be.
Okay, luck has changed.
Our luck has changed, everybody.
Here comes the offer.
He's malding.
He's raging.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
Right.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
The offer did go.
Not even 400K.
Come on.
Not even 400.
No deal.
Not even 400K.
That's ridiculous.
That's so ridiculous.
Banker's so stingy.
I know, right?
Imagine he offers you more than a million.
Let's go with 19.
Our girl Junji-Ni never lets us down.
Open the case.
Oh, God.
One more case.
Number 16.
Melanie.
Open the case.
750.
Guys, how is there still one cent on the board?
What do you think is going to happen?
I don't know.
hello okay okay okay new offer new offer yeah what it went
down no way wait did it actually or no deal why did it go
down this banker is so stingy i know we lost one million but
Like, come on.
One more case.
I'm going to do 18.
Open the case.
There you go.
A dollar versus a million.
I mean, not even a dollar.
It's a penny versus a million.
Okay.
I cannot.
I can't with this.
Why not?
No.
You guys, this is an insane deal.
This is insane.
Holy cow.
One kiss.
It sounded like he said one kiss.
What are you trying to say, Howie Mendo?
How do I get to kiss one of these lovely ladies?
Oh, there's a spider on my wall.
I'll go away.
I hate summer time.
Oh my gosh.
14.
Mandy.
Open the case.
What is going on right now?
What is actually happening?
I can't...
Oh, wait, wait, did that go up?
Oh my god, it's so insane.
You have your $13 million money.
No deal.
This is the highest deal I think I'll ever see ever.
This is insane.
This is, what is happening?
Oh my god, oh my god.
On your case.
Busting.
Here we go with 23.
Open the case.
We lost the penny.
Play a mini-game.
Okay.
what well this is awkward you only needed to cheat to barely
win to each round choose one of your remaining cases to be
removed if you remove if you choose a money case you'll
continue playing if you choose an empty case your game is
over each round you avoid the empty you will earn even more
money you may quit at any time in between rounds to keep
your winnings okay ready push your luck oh me five ready
push your luck ready push your luck ready push your luck
Guys, it's 50-50.
What should I pick?
Pick six.
Lady Luck Be Kind.
Win 1 million or more in a single game.
Let's go.
Or more?
A little bird told me.
Unlock criteria.
Oh, pick a case that contains at least 1 million as the
first case of any game in any mode.
Achieve a bank total of $250,000 or more.
Yep, achieve a bank total of $500,000 or more.
$1 million or more.
Let's go.
Wait, what's our, um...
What's our, uh...
I want to see what our...
Awards are.
How many are we missing?
Oh wow, there's a lot of them!
There's so many.
Wow.
Supplemental.
Blackjack time?
Yeah, let's do blackjack.
I cannot believe it actually came down to 1 million.
I mean, it was like 3 1 million.
But it was 1 million versus 1 penny.
I can't believe that happened.
Ready?
Push.
Your luck.
Blackjack!
Versus the computer.
Oh, that's the most mint thing ever.
Hello and welcome to Blackjack.
What just happened?
Wait, what?
Oh, we're playing in the thousands.
Hit?
Oh, hit me.
Hit.
I would have lost another one.
Wait, where's the double down?
Hit.
Ooh, hit.
Guys, have I won any money or?
Hit.
What?
I think I'm done.
I think I'm done playing.
I think I'm done playing DR-N-O-D.
What is wrong?
Thank you.
I think I'm just gonna go.
That's okay, Zero, because you're priceless.
Aww, you're too kind.
This was a lot of fun.
This was such a roller coaster of emotions, wasn't it?
No.
We've had some real highs.
We had some real lows.
But in the end, I had to cheat to win.
And even then, it was barely.
You have terrible luck.
You can't count cards.
You're addicted to gambling.
You pick cases poorly.
But what do you mean?
But it's just picking cases.
What else am I supposed to do?
How am I supposed to win?
When it comes to being lucky, she's cursed.
When it comes to being loved, she's cursed.
Okay, hold on.
Let me, uh...
I'm gonna quit.
Oh, gosh.
I wonder what the leaderboard looks like.
Oh, I need some more water.
Give me one second.
I'm gonna actually switch this over.
I need a break after that.
Today I was so...
It was funny because I was like...
I was like...
Since I did Outer Wilds yesterday, I'm doing...
I'm doing like a no brain game today.
So...
It's a good thing you're cute, Mint.
You're like...
Um, I was like, I'm doing a no-brain game today.
It'll be so easy.
And I'm just so sad.
I'm just so...
I'm just so sad.
Oh, god.
Oh, man.
Actually, yeah, we'll just...
That was fun, guys.
Thank you.
My luck is either a hundred or negative.
This is a lot of fun.
Two!
Thank you, thank you!
I might be showing my age, but I will always remember Howie
Mandela's the voice of Bobby from Bobby's World.
What's Bobby's World?
Uh-oh, you're showing your age, Virilin.
Uh-oh.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I have no idea.
Apache slot stream flashbacks Gambling is so fun As long as
it's fake money For me at least Right I'm actually going to
raid somebody today I'm going to raid somebody today I think
hopefully I can raid her I will see Neither 100 or negative
It's more like 100 negative
But me Miori, Miori Celesto is playing, um...
She's playing Red Dead Redemption.
So let me see if I can raid her.
Uh, no, sorry.
She's not playing...
That's Calliope.
Sorry, it showed up on my, like...
It showed up on my thing.
She's playing Metal Gear Solid!
Okay, I need to go sleep.
I need to go rest, I think.
Oh no, it's not showing up.
I don't know if I can raid her.
I don't think it'll let me raid Koliapy.
I don't imagine they have that turned on.
Um, shoot.
I wonder if I could, maybe if I put in her URL.
Thanks for the stream and keep on gambling as long as it's
fake.
Thank you.
Wait, did she finish or did she just start?
I can't tell.
Oh, it says loading.
I think she just started.
Hold on.
Let me see if I put in her URL.
It'll work.
I'm always nervous about writing people because I, um, I
don't want them to be uncomfortable.
Um, this is the most hype and pain in a few hours ever,
James.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for joining me.
This was a grand old time.
It was so much fun.
Paste.
Oh, yeah.
says I can't.
Okay, I'm just gonna post the link to her stream then if you
want to watch Miyori play.
She just started, it seems like.
So, um...
Miyori playing MGS2.
You can go a man... We'll just manual raid.
It's the sand.
It absolutely is the sand.
We'll just say that.
Okay, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys and have a good night.
Tomorrow is Tokyo Jungle.
Tokyo Jungle, so I'm excited about that.
We'll see how our luck fairs there instead.
What a blast this was.
Hopefully next time I do a game show stream like this, maybe
we can make it a collab with some other VTubers.
We'll see who's available.
Look, thanks for two months.
Thank you.
But, um, oh gosh, I think I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go bed rot
now because I'm just so sad.
You guys, enjoy the rest of your evening.
Have a good night or day or whatever.
This is, this is what I always say.
I'm unlucky so that you guys can be lucky, right?
I, I will absorb all your bad luck so that you guys can have
all the luck in the world all the good things can happen to
you guys.
I take the fall.
I take the fall for it.
I'm blessing your gotcha pulls right now.
Which reminds me, I need to go try in Blue Archive because I
got Bunny Asana, but I want to get Bunny Karin and...
Who was the other one?
They were both Uniques.
NERU!
Yeah, buddy NERU Okay!
What's up, Minto?
Bye, guys.
Bye, bye.
Bye, bye!
Oh, and don't forget if you want to go manually raise a
miori.
Also, who said...
Who said Blue Archive got your polling stream when...
Will a fortune with friends would go hard?
Oh, I'd love to see that.
Wheel of Fortune.
I mean, not Wheel of Fortune.
Who said blue art?
I'm mixing.
I'm just going to go to bed.
Good night.
On Suminto.
Eat the last time.